thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air which now comes
with nebula for free get 40% off of both
with a documentary distancing discount
link in the description for the best
thing he's done it's worth just bringing
up some the music video here kitty-kitty
about Carroll killing her husband you
have to admit that these songs are a
little catchy
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because today we are covering
tiger king and oh man this one almost
broke me there are so many legal issues
to go into so many legal acts these
people really needed better lawyers if
you don't know tiger king is the
documentary about a bunch of zoo owners
who take care of big cats like tigers
lions and ligers feels a little
sensationalized because this is really
only the tip of the iceberg I had to do
a whole bunch of extra research to dig
into the various court cases that this
created truth is really stranger than
fiction about an hour ago we had an
incident where one of the employees
stuck their arm through the cage and a
tiger tore her arm off I can give you
your money back or I can give you a rain
check and spoilers we're gonna go into
the murder the conspiracy the Tigers and
even trademark law
[Music]
so be sure to comment in the form of an
objection which I will either sustain or
overrule and stick around until the end
of the video where i give tiger king a
grade for legal realism so without
further ado let's dig in to tiger king
here is a fact that may make you stop
for a second there are more captive
Tigers in the u.s. today then there are
in the wild throughout the world and you
would not believe how many sheriffs told
me oh yeah just down the street there's
a guy that has a lion or a guy down
there that has a tiger
they just feel very strongly that these
are mine and nobody's gonna take them
from me ok so right off the bat let's
talk about the legality of owning big
cats because a ton of people reached out
to me and asked how it was even possible
that these crazy people could own these
lions and tigers well the reason is
because there's no federal law that
actually bans the private ownership of
big cats there is a patchwork of state
laws that some ban outright ownership of
big cats some require regulations for
owning big cats there's no federal law
that says you can't own big cats so
whether you personally can own a big cat
like Joe exotic depends largely on what
state you live in and whether that state
prohibits the ownership of wildlife now
there are some federal laws that do
provide some regulation in this context
like the Endangered Species Act which
permits the sale of big cats without a
permit from the US Fish & Wildlife
Department and in 2016 there was
actually a case that applied the
Endangered Species Act not only to
animals that are found in the wild but
also to animals that are held in
captivity so that's a relatively new
part of this law and then there's the
Animal Welfare Act which sets certain
minimal standards for actually caring
for a lot of these animals and big cats
and requires you to get a permit to
exhibit these things to the public and
interestingly Tim Stark who is featured
later on in this documentary had his
permit permanently revoked by the
federal government so he can't exhibit
animals to the public anymore and it
probably won't surprise you that
Oklahoma has some of the Laxus laws in
the United States when it comes to
owning exotic animals which is why Joe
exotic was able to have his zoo in
Oklahoma
there's always been a rumor out there
that Doc Intel euthanizes his cubs when
he's done with them we've had
whistleblowers come to us and say that
they've heard a gunshot in the middle of
the night the next day there's no cat
but they don't know where the cat went
yeah so there are all kinds of
allegations in this documentary not just
that Joe exotic but other zoo owners
would kill the big cats once they were
no longer young enough to be handled by
the general public you can imagine that
once they get to be a certain age they
become ferocious killing machines and
are no longer cuddly animals that you
can hold in your hands and so once they
lose their economic value effectively
these zoo owners would euthanize them
and under most circumstances it is
illegal to kill big cats under the
Animal Welfare Act so spoiler alert one
of the things that Joe is eventually
convicted of is a violation of this act
because he's accused of killing a bunch
of tigers without a permit they said
that Joe had shot five Tigers and they
dug him up and found the skulls so
there's a big difference between being
able to actually legally own one of
these animals and being able to take
care of it or being able to euthanize it
those are very separate questions I told
Joe how are you gonna make money how you
gonna make money how you going money he
didn't have any other way to make money
other than cub pitting so he had to
breathe this is another question that
kept cropping up in terms of whether
you're allowed to breed these big cats
and under federal law as long as you
have a USDA license you can in fact
breed big cats though some states in
particular have banned breeding for
obvious reasons because it's ripe for
abuse so again there's a difference
between federal law and state law in
terms of whether you're allowed to breed
them there's no federal law that's that
says you can't as long as you have a
permit but a lot of states do in fact
prohibit that
[Music]
the arm is completely gone we do not
have time to work get everything out of
it out of the driveway all right this is
such a sad affair where the employee was
so grievously injured in terms of
whether the zoo is liable States again
differ in terms of how they impose
liability for injuries that are caused
by these exotic animals some states hold
the zoo's what's called strictly liable
which means that as long as there is an
injury related to the animals the zoo is
responsible regardless of whether they
were negligent or not other states
require that the zoo's be actually
negligent in terms of an employee being
injured or not you can imagine that
based on some of the things that are in
this documentary it probably wouldn't be
too hard to show that Joe and some of
the other staff at the zoo might have
been negligent in terms of allowing this
person to be injured I've been doing
this 20 years never even been but we
don't have all of the facts in this
particular case I think this documentary
made it a point not to show too much of
the footage related to this employee
being injured there might be defenses
the the zoo might have like contributory
negligence or assumption of risk where
perhaps the employee might not have been
exercising all of the caution that she
should have been using so it's not
necessarily an open and shut case and
just because you have a legal claim or a
lawsuit on your hands doesn't
necessarily mean that you're gonna
recover anything there's been so many
lawsuits against Joe exotic in the GW
Zoo that it's entirely possible that
even if this employee won the lawsuit
that she might not be able to recover
anything that's called being
judgment-proof and it's unfortunately a
sad reality where sometimes the guilty
party just doesn't have any funds to
compensate an injury for someone that
deserves it it's probably gonna get me
in trouble but
he's uh you don't meet you it was a
truck that picked up me from all these
Walmart's on there and they have expired
Joe would let them pick out what they
wanted first then carrying bags of us
expired meat and foods back for their
mobile home and that's what they ate oh
my god this violates so many health and
safety codes and osha in so many
different ways I'm not even gonna go
into it this is actually worse than
Willy Wonka's sweatshop factory which I
covered in an episode of laws broken so
if you want to know how many laws Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory broke
you can check out that episode spoiler
alert it's a lot of laws I was a power
of attorney for both of them who was the
power of attorney on the new documents
Carol produced know me that new power
attorney gave her control over the
estate ah the will and the power of
attorney being changed in a very
suspicious way right before Carol's
husband goes missing at first blush this
I think looks pretty terrible but I
don't think that this is nearly as bad
as it appears and hear me out on this as
it happens you cannot execute a durable
power of attorney without two witnesses
and a notary and the notary will
actually record that they witnessed the
the signatures being provided
now that law actually changed in 2011
we're now under Florida durable and non
durable powers of attorney have to be
with two witnesses and a notary before
that only durable powers of attorney
meaning that a power of attorney that
applies when someone is incapacitated or
goes missing for example so I think the
law at the time required two witnesses
and a notary which means it's unlikely
that there was any foul play involved in
her husband would have had to have
signed off on this particular power of
attorney so it probably was not executed
posthumously now on top of that there is
this potentially suspicious language
about kicking in when the person
disappears that doesn't seem like
something that often happens isn't it
suspicious that the power of attorney
says upon my disappearance is that
normal verbage I have in 37 years never
seen it say or disappearance never had I
just did a little bit of research to
find out if this disappearance language
is normal and as it happens I was able
to find another power of attorney that
mentions disappearance which makes sense
if someone is incapacitated if they go
into a coma if they disappear if they
are killed that's when you want a
durable power of attorney for someone to
be able to take care of the things in
the estate the documentary seems to
indicate that it's only applicable in
disappearance I think that they sort of
cherry-pick to this one section I would
bet that the the rest of the power of
attorney mentions a whole bunch of
different situations where the power of
attorney kicks in so I could be wrong I
don't have all of the facts but I don't
think this is nearly as suspicious as
its portrayed in the documentary I got a
phone call stating that the office alarm
had gone off and Carol was there her and
Kenny far had cut the locks on the gate
cut the locks on the office the will and
the power turning they were all taken
out of the office that day so we talked
about the potentially suspicious
language of the power of attorney now a
lot of those accusations came from and
McQueen Don's old assistant who talks
about a lot of these things and
certainly cast aspersions on Carol
Baskin interestingly there was a
conservatorship case for Dawn's estate
that accuses Anne McQueen of embezzling
six hundred thousand dollars from Don's
properties if indeed these allegations
are true that certainly paints her
aspersions at a different light and
would explain why Carol did not want and
accessing all of the documents that were
in Dawn's office but this is Florida so
I assume some light embezzlement is
probably okay Joe decided that the way
he would get back at us was to rename
his traveling show big cat rescue
entertainment here's our logo alright
and here is
what he started using all right now we
get into the real sexy stuff the
trademark infringement cases so I had to
look into this there were federal
lawsuits filed there were some trademark
cases and there were some copyright
cases and from what I can tell the
trademark infringement suit is basically
as it's portrayed in the documentary
Caryl Baskin had the trademark to Big
Cat Rescue for a very long time and then
it appears that Joe exotic wanted to
create confusion between Big Cat Rescue
and his own entertainment company joke
started realizing that he made his name
close to the cat rescue when they google
it it might pull him up first you're not
allowed to do that that's the entire
point of trademark trademark exists to
prevent consumer confusion and trademark
is not necessarily the graphics although
it can include the graphics but it also
includes just the word mark itself so
the big cat rescue versus big cat rescue
entertainment that's gonna be a
slam-dunk trademark case for trademark
infringement false designation of origin
and unfair competition it's not
surprising then that Carol got a
judgment for close to a million dollars
nine hundred and fifty three thousand
dollars because Joe couldn't help
himself and he probably admitted that he
tried to create confusion between the
two entities that one lawsuit was about
the rabbit photo and the other lawsuit
was about a bunch of photos where he
would take a picture of Carol and take
her head and put it on the body of a man
in a diaper so these copyright cases and
that there are at least two of them
possibly three copyright cases are a
little different from the trademark case
that we just talked about so this may or
may not be meritorious but Joe obviously
would use graphics in his reality TV
show in his internet videos and he may
not have been using them in a fair use
way
I'm so exotic and we're gonna make an
honest woman out of this and what Carol
did is sort of diabolical and genius
because what she did is she went and
tracked down the people that took the
photos that Joe use so maybe they were
posted on Facebook or on the internet
and she would track down the people who
took the photos of big cat rescue or her
husband or herself and she would buy the
rights to those photos she would get
what's called a copyright assignment and
then with the ownership of the copyright
procured she then sued Joe for copyright
infringement for using the photos that
then she had the rights to Carol Baskin
credit where credit is due
it's clever she'll never get a Maine
dollars anyway I don't know anything I
don't anything just bust that's not mine
those cars are not mine not stupid okay
this may be my favorite part of all of
tiger King you can keep the conspiracy
to commit murder you can keep the tigers
and lions my favorite thing are the
fraudulent transfers Joe kept thinking
if he changed the name it would just
derail them and derail them one didn't
if they just moved it to another lawsuit
contrary to what Joe and and Jeff Lowe
say you can't avoid judgments or avoid
lawsuits just by changing the name of
the company or just taking the assets
and moving them somewhere else
that's called a fraudulent transfer it
creates what's called a constructive
trust over the transferred assets so if
you take possession of those assets that
were fraudulently transferred the person
who is rightfully owning that property
which as as we saw Carol got a judgment
for almost a million dollars so she
could have gotten almost everything that
the GW zoo owned that person can then
claw back all of that property that was
transferred somewhere else so what I
think happened here is that Joe exotics
mom Shirley Sri Vogel wasn't sued per se
but what it looks like is that Joe put
some documents in front of her
where it on paper transferred the assets
of the zoo itself or the things that the
zoo owned and put it in her name I went
down to the courthouse and got a one of
the copy of one of the deeds and I said
grandma are you aware that this happened
and she said well he shoved a paper in
front of me and told me an assignment I
didn't think anything of it obviously
when they signed these documents and
engaged in knowingly or unknowingly in a
fraudulent transfer with Joe their
involvement almost certainly required a
lawyer and it really seemed like she
rubber stamped things that she really
shouldn't have been rubber stamping
Shirley's name is on everything
the trailers the water bill the electric
bill the cable you know cable bills yeah
you can't get away with that and I'm
sorry that the Joe seemingly took
advantage of her but Shirley Sri Vogel
did sign a settlement agreement with Big
Cat Rescue Corp which is the one owned
by Carol Baskin not the the fake one
owned by Joe where she agreed that she
had engaged in these transfers so let
that be a lesson to all those parents
out there don't sign paperwork just
because your kids put it in front of you
they might be engaging in fraud
especially if they live in Florida one
time I was on the park and Joe's talking
to me says hey I hear you can take care
of a problem for me in Florida
that's what problem that B says Carol
basket I said no I can't all right now
we're getting into the real juicy stuff
here the conspiracy to commit murder now
you might be wondering when does idle
chitchat go from mere conversation into
a conspiracy to commit murder well under
18 USC 1958 which is the use of
interstate commerce facilities and the
commission for murder for hire
it applies whenever someone travels or
causes another to travel between states
and and that's sort of a relic of the
federalism and a lot of federal statutes
only apply in interstate situations so
that they don't interfere with
state-based laws but as long as you use
the mail or interstate commerce with the
intent that a murder be committed in
violation of the laws of the United
States or if you exchange anything of
Cocoon
you value with anyone who conspires to
commit such an act here guilty of
effectively attempted murder and under
18 USC 371 which is the federal statute
that deals with conspiracy all that you
need to do is conduct one overt act in
furtherance of that conspiracy and that
overt act does not need to be one of the
elements of that offense so it's a
pretty low burden certainly paying
$3,000 would definitely be considered an
overt act in furtherance of a conspiracy
to commit murder but I think this
documentary is conflating a couple
different things there are the things
that are required to prove the crime and
then there are the things that the US
Attorney's want so that they have an
easy time proving the crime and those
are not necessarily the same things when
I did become psychotic
that's my going to Tampa gonna really
just the fact that the guy started
driving towards Carroll Baskin probably
would have been enough in its own right
to convict both of these people of
conspiracy to commit murder I was like
hey Joe this is my guy this is the guy
who will whack Carroll for you really
how much you know when I said I was
gonna do a reaction to Tiger King I got
so many comments from people that said
that Joe was set up and that the
government had committed entrapment
while entrapment is a defense it's very
very rarely applicable and a valid
entrapment defense has two elements one
you have to prove that the government
induced the crime itself and two you
have to prove the defendants lack of
predisposition to engage in the criminal
conduct in other words that the
government put the idea of the crime
itself into the defendants head and
that's just simply not the case here at
least based on what we're seeing in this
documentary I don't think Joe has any
reasonable grounds to claim that he was
a victim of entrapment
sweet as wine butter husband win
disappear
got a little crazy got a little
and the cop said is something wrong here
the best thing he's done it's worth just
bringing up some the music video here
kitty-kitty about Carol killing her
husband you have to admit that these
songs are a little catchy a lot of
people were asking about whether Carol
Baskin could have a defamation claim
against Joe exotic based on the fact
that he's basically accusing her of
killing her ex-husband funny story about
these songs Joe isn't the one singing in
these songs the songs were actually
recorded by two individuals named Vince
Johnson and Danny Clinton who were two
musicians from Washington State
apparently they reached out to Joe
exotic and for my understanding they
were paid in influence I don't think
that Carol Baskin could have a
defamation claim based on the content of
these songs it's sort of Joe's opinion
there's some factual basis for it I'm
not sure that you could say he was
negligent and making this claim if it is
indeed false and you might argue that
Carol Baskin is a limited purpose
celebrity and therefore you would have
to use a higher standard for defamation
I don't think that there's gonna be much
of a claim here after just three short
hours nearly four hours the jury came
back finding Joseph Maldonado passage
guilty on all 19 guilty I don't know
about you but after watching Tiger King
I had to find out what happened to all
these people after the show ended for
better or worse Joe exotic is in federal
prison in Texas where he's currently
suffering from an infection of the
corona virus rotavirus is a really
terrible thing and it's infecting a ton
of people in jail because they're in
close quarters I highly recommend
following Scott Hechinger who's a public
defender in Brooklyn he's been at the
forefront of advocating for prisoners
rights and I think it's definitely
something you should look into because
it's not just something that affected
Joe exotic Joe has filed a lawsuit
seeking nearly 94 million dollars in
damages against the Department of
Interior and the prosecutors and the the
documentarians behind the show he's
going to lose that suit I feel very
confident the GW Zoo is still open and
is
run by Jeff Lowe at least it was open
until it was also shut down for
coronavirus reasons as you can imagine a
lot of people want to go there because
of the infamy of this show and because
we live in the dumbest timeline Jo is
seeking a presidential pardon and
president Trump is actually considering
it I'll take a look is that your exotic
that's Jo exciting why
but now let's give Tiger King a grade
for legal realism the characters are
completely unbelievable they're mere
caricatures the dialogue is insane and
the factual scenarios are completely
ridiculous it would never happen so I
give Tiger king in F for legal realism
what what's that
oh oh it's real life all right shut it
down shut it down I am never gonna
financially recover from this now even
though this video is fair use commentary
and criticism on this ridiculous
documentary I still get copyright claims
all the time because people abuse the
legal system the only thing worse than
being mauled by a tiger is getting
demonetised which is why my creator
friends and I teamed up to build our own
platform where creators don't need to
worry about D monetization or the
dreaded algorithm it's called nebula and
we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream if you like tiger king
you love nebula and curiosity stream
because nebula is a place where creators
can do what they do best create it's a
place where we can both house our
content ad-free and experiment with
original content and new series that
probably wouldn't work on youtube in
fact if you liked this episode of real
lawyer reax the version i put on nebula
removes this ad and contains a blooper
reel expired meat delicious one more
time here we go nebula features tons of
YouTube's top educational creators like
Lindsay Ellis have is interesting
knowing better real engineering in tears
ooh and tons of others and we get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on YouTube like Tom Scott's amazing game
show money where he pits a bunch of
famous youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
either work together or profit
individually it's so so good so what
does this have to do with curiosity
stream well as the go-to source for the
best documentaries on the internet they
love educational
content and educational creators and we
worked out a deal where if you sign up
for curiosity stream with a link in the
description not only will you get a
one-month free trial for curiosity
stream but you'll also get a nebula
subscription for free and to be clear
that nebula subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as your curiosity
stream member and for a limited time
curiosity stream is offering their
documentary distancing discount which
gives you 40% off all of their annual
plans and gift cards so you can stay in
and stay curious and that's $12 a year
for both curiosity stream and nebula
since we've got to stay inside anyway we
might as well be soothed by the voice of
David Attenborough or take a ride across
the universe with Chris Hatton film or
just watch Tom Scott torture your
favorite youtubers so if you click the
link in the description you'll get both
nebula and curiosity stream for 40% off
or you can go to curiosity stream comm
slash legal eagle it's a great way to
support this channel and educational
content directly for just $12 per year
so click on the link in the description
or again go to curiosity stream comm
slash legal eagle clicking on the link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my grade for Tiger King for
legal realism leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other legal
reactions where if you click it I'll see
you in court